[Music]
Samuel leads here and I've actually got
in my house one of my success students
who has been working with me now for
about four months and not only is she
financially free which means that your
passive income is equal to a greater
than your living expenses
she must be ultimately financially free
right now because her passive income is
getting ridiculously high so well come
on to the show Lesley Thank You Samuel
pleasure to be here how you feeling I
feel great you got to be honored
actually yeah well I'm on for you to be
here how much money you making passive
income right now right now is I'm on
about six and a half six and a half
thousand pounds yeah but as of next
month I'll be on 16 and a half sorry
sorry what seven plus six and a half oh
geez don't do this to me is it thirteen
and a half there you go boom
thirteen and a half thousand pounds
passive income and you can't even add
seven plus six yeah I always say that
when I'm doing my training you don't
have to be you have to be super smart to
be successful what do you need Leslie
you tell me I mean you've you know
you're crushing it because you started
four months ago you didn't have any
deals in England no no deals
you got background in Dubai yes I had
Tommy tell me what does it take to have
that kind of success I think it's a
mindset yeah yeah mine shaft and mindset
and just just get on with it
attitude and it really helps to have a
mentor yeah because I don't actually
think I would have got here so fast had
I not had one yeah yeah I'm sort of
educated welcome for training and had
some education on the way when did we
first meet how did you how did you get
on this how that happened well I met you
before you met me because I saw young
YouTube cool yeah so I was because I
relocated back from Dubai to UK after
spending about eight years out there in
January so I was a bit I was a bit
nervous about what what I was gonna do
back here because I felt like well I was
gonna start from zero again and build up
my income or my wall when you say start
from zero again how did that happen and
why did you have to start over again I
did we do well we had talked about me
and my husband we do have passive income
from Dubai yeah but for me because we're
moving
away at some point that would have to
stop so in my head I set the gang back
to zero
sure yeah that makes sense yeah and have
you done this with your husband's help
or have you been responsible for this um
of course with his help because he's in
the background so he's really good at
all the techie stuff which we'll
probably talk about a bit later of how
that sort of connects with what I'm
doing yeah yeah but I think family
supports paramount yes my parents tell
me what your role has been in this so
what have you done and how have you
received of course you've received help
from you know me and the family on the
Academy and all the training but what
have you actually done and what has been
your strategy to earn six and a half
thousand pounds soon to be thirteen and
a half thousand pounds a month in
passive income like have you done that
what would your strategy mean well when
I came back there were so many
strategies right that when you're on
training that you learn about I just
wanted to do rent to rent and for for
the first part so phase one and the
reason for that is because I wanted to
put as little money as possible down
into a property and type tied up but
with the highest cash flow yeah yeah so
I've just focused on that strategy and
went for it so you've not been you
didn't have a big stash of money that
you've been buying properties with no I
have actually brought any properties so
all the money I currently make is not
from property I own myself but I control
those properties absolutely yeah and
what you've done as well which is which
is a really good strategy is you've
combined rent to rent with also serviced
accommodation yes that wasn't the
initial strategy though but it's sort of
snowboard into that way I think I sent a
picture she to you in my Academy group
or Alec having me great yeah I think it
was like I needed like 20 properties or
something based on a net of 600 pounds a
month to get to like ten thousand which
is a lot of houses yeah and we've got
how I'm just saying quick sums again
we've got what was the new one coming up
that would be five properties Wow not a
lot of properties but getting that sort
of net income level has been it's been
amazing amazing journey I didn't know
that I could do that here that's a ball
so what have you learned then cuz when
did you go on the crash course with me
is that the end of January
this year yeah this year this year
physically this year
yes I met you at the end of Jan I felt
like I knew you already that's
incredible so what happened after that
well I went away yeah well actually I
didn't I joined your Academy right away
yeah yeah and we just like you you're
fast-track risk-taking kind of person
yeah because I just think that you can't
really go wrong to education it really
is what you also bring to the table you
mentor what you want out there I really
believe in that so remember when you
know the crash course was for two days
and at the end of day I was all signed
up to go on your Academy and so the next
time I had a proper chat with you was on
a one-to-one I think that was February
yeah yeah for a month we sat down in my
office yes with a nice one-to-one mat
take your game plan yeah and then you
started crushing it
yeah did you did you have I know you had
some money to start with so how much
money you're making our 69th grand
passive income that's going to go up to
13 and a half grand passive income once
you get this next deal which is just the
best door ever how much of your own
money have you had to put down to get
all these regiment properties and
accommodations about eight and a half
thousand I think and then you also
invested into the Academy as well right
yeah so that was additional yeah yeah
some yeah I I really believe in truly
heavily investing in the training yeah
oh yeah why that's so important well I
don't think I've got here that fast you
know because I didn't know what the
property language was the business
language when I came back to the UK and
so I think that having some sort or some
sort of support group people that are
very successful doing really well that
sort of just steamrolls you forward yeah
don't yeah well I I know I know I'm a
competitive person but or at least when
other people crushing it and all this
person is just a to lease option
agreement deals this person's just flip
ten houses in the last month it makes
you it becomes the norm absolutely yeah
so so you're you're doing seriously well
your strategies rent to rent serviced
accommodation why did you pick that
strategy because I wanted to put the
least amount of money down from our
pocket yeah into
property that would generate the highest
cash flow every month that was my
strategy and how are you finding these
brilliant deals so well word-of-mouth
and networking community yeah I didn't I
know like normally people go down the
real estate agent route right and do and
they market themselves out to homeowners
yeah and I think that strategy is great
but for me I rather do the networking
face-to-face if possible and then if
people like me then they'll get the word
out
etc so that's been quite effective like
you know what your community and you
you're like the biggest hit on the
académie like you're getting calls from
other Academy embers all the time and
you're a very giving person thank you
you're not just a what can I get what
can I get you're really given with your
knowledge with your skills your energy
and you light up every room you're going
to there's that there's I think it's a
Chinese proverb that says if you want to
go fast go alone but if you want to go
far then go together I like that you
ever heard of that before it's a Chinese
form of oh no I think tapping into a
community which you're really good at
your great networker
getting people around you and working
with people in collaborations is
fantastic so tell me how do you manage
to what's your what's your number one
tip to networking well and having people
really around you besides of course just
joining the Academy like what have you
done how have you made that but I think
the most important thing to do is if you
have a small family we have a big family
you've got to reach out to everyone and
tell them what you're doing yeah yeah
that's quite important tell the world
you're a property investor yeah
basically so that's that's the first
starting point and then when you won't
for me I I have a lot I have a fairly
good amount of confidence but if you
don't that's a first starting block and
then tell your mom or tell your dad or
tell the people closest to you to you
know spread the word for you love that
you know I meet a lot of people and they
are they come on the crash course and
they want to be a secret entrepreneur
you know like a like a closeted property
investor and their plan is to slowly and
quietly alongside their job not tell
their family not to anymore to become
financially free and then go tada
but in my experience it doesn't work
like that because you'll you'll only see
it when you believe it
first and if you really truly believe it
you're gonna tell the world
yeah it's Hosni and also it's nice to
work with a family involved as well
right because you know oh yeah I helped
you with that or I've got a mom or dad
or cousin thank you so much for
introducing me to this person you know
let's go for a meal you know I could
talk to you about it that sort of thing
yeah so tell me a bit about these deals
then because you've not you initially
thought that you needed when we had our
first one to one yeah thought that you
needed 20 properties to reach a net
profit of ten thousand pounds a month
but actually you've done that with way
more than that with five or six
properties yeah well yeah we lessen so
give me the give me a case study of an
attempt an example I want to give me
your first deer your first property deal
get run through I know your your skill
is just kind of like networking and all
that sort of stuff but try wanna know
the numbers so give me the numbers so
I'll talk to you about two deals yes on
the first of March I got two sets of
keys one was for house which was going
to be a mini HMO so four rooms okay and
the other case was for a two-bedroom
flat and I actually took that flat on as
hey let's give this a go so that that
flat first when you took it on you went
to get on the landlord
what was his situation he's got this to
bed flat how much rent is he getting
bought at the moment what was it doing
so the to bed flat the rent was 1,300 is
he renting it out nope so I'm renting
that flat so you mean before he met you
before I think it was empty because the
previous tenant there had sort of not
paid their rent that was I yeah but they
were also doing a service accommodation
type of business yeah yeah but they for
some reason like the the property was a
little bit damaged right and but it was
in a really central location in
Cambridge so he's a bit of a frustrated
landlord of a slightly damaged property
yeah much joy and I think there were
friends before so I don't know you know
so that was I was sorry to hear about
that cuz so you met him you found him
through networking or didn't you think
actually a man from my cousin yes it is
a couple and they were so they're so
nice yeah you know and the
basically wanted to rent their flat out
said okay this is what I want to do with
that is that a keg you know
are you go would you be okay and this is
what I'm going to do to the place Josh I
show you though some pictures of what I
was going to do inside I'll redecorate
it up and I told them you know don't
worry you'll rent always be on time and
I'll manage the place etc and how did he
say to that it's quite happy I think I
think this is the best bit about
networking for your community there's
already a level of reputation and Trust
there yeah you know so it makes things
much easier yeah yeah well yeah where I
speak when I went through try and find a
property or a real estate agent there
was just quite a lot more a lot more
involved right like referencing of
course it's a new company it's very hard
yeah yeah because obviously had to set
up a company to run this business so
rule number one is to just speak to the
people that you know first off your
community your friends your family so
what did you offer him then so he in his
mind he's thinking I'm not getting any
rent right now for this house if it was
noised I'd maybe get thirteen hundred
pounds a month on a general ast contract
what did you offer him so what offers
him the the rent was 1,300 yeah that's a
that didn't change okay but I offered
him a guaranteed rent over a certain
number how many years so three years
yeah yeah and and I would look after the
place or a company would look after
place so if there was no management fees
involved so this is all part the rent to
rent sake and I'm just thinking what uh
no points there obviously was a great
deal for him yeah with a guaranteed rate
obviously those were out void periods
thirteen hundred pound month which is
the going right anyway guaranteed
maintenance cleaning that's in one pack
so how are you making money from that so
this is this is the part where it
clicked with serviced accommodation
because with the HMO house that we took
on the same month right that is netting
is still good about a little bit of
eight hundred pounds a month month
profit right yeah profit yeah and the to
bed but the too bad apartment in the
first month on our books 1800 a little
bit over was not net profits so just
stick with the first property so the
property that you're gay you're paying
thirteen hundred pounds a month to the
guy how much did you they met now
I was out for on service accommodation
in the first month or first property it
was a little bit over 4,000 turn over
the first month yeah so you pay him
1,300 correct and then you then bring in
a total turnover of 4,000 in your first
month yeah I'm a profit of that is yours
because of course you've got cost of
service accommodation yeah absolutely so
it's about 1800 profit profit so you
made one that has an 800 profit in your
first month yeah deal yeah and that is
that like how did you make so much
profit in that month this is what the
husband and wife team come into play
so firstly because my husband's not here
in England he's in Dubai yeah yeah so my
husband was doing all the bookings
online yeah so front through the service
accommodation platform booking calm air
B&B all the places yeah and yes if he's
doing that quite well so we have like
little marketing angles and for us it's
all about ours our theme is that color
popping and I think that makes your
property stand out when you're
advertising online of course yeah and
also we don't offer our rooms at low
rate so the strategy is we offer them
out on a high rate first and then when
they don't get filled out then we offer
like this counts excellent yeah so
that's just one deal how did you feel
when the money came in in that first
property we just like oh my gosh yeah I
was flabbergasted because I didn't think
I didn't know what to expect I didn't
think it would did that well but it did
yeah and and I'm so pleased because I
suppose that's our niche
we're so we go in at the high end of
service accommodation yes yeah and
tomorrow you're gonna be spending a day
with me yeah my serviced accommodation
trainer yes what are you hoping to learn
tomorrow sounds like you're killing it
with serviced accommodation already
serviced accommodation the reason why
you can earn such high yields is
obviously because it's more fiddly on
the management side yeah but also some
legal stuff as well right yes yeah so I
want to make sure that I've got it all
covered off it's because I like the law
because of my background yes your
background is lawyer you're a lawyer
so tomorrow and that's what I think is
your I've said this to you already your
pharmacy right now I think the next step
that we need to we're working on right
now
is is really system wise and things
getting you some staff you can now
forward yes
yeah system washing the heck out of it I
know and because I've been driving
there's nothing wrong with that I'm
still gonna be driving I've been driving
my family's like like was it called like
a battered car yeah because it's where
we do our heavy lifting get furniture in
so like I'm really excited because I was
thinking today maybe or when I'm in
Wolverhampton for the week I'm going to
do a bit of car shopping on a lease
option of course of course see the the
business skills as well that you're now
using I would never have thought about I
would have never gone for that before
honestly if you hadn't learnt about you
know benefits of having stuff in and the
lease you know yeah ya know gonna be
like what's going on with when we have
our one-to-one which was literally only
a few months ago now we talked about
development as well yeah so I think
that's going to be a next thing for you
what are you hoping to do on the
development side of things
we have some family projects coming up
next yeah so gonna be developing some
blocks of flats had a chat of my dad
he's my sensei mentor yeah and he said
he sent me a task which is which I'm
telling you now because you're gonna
hold me accountable but he wants me to
do something really big so in his mind
he's like Leslie why don't you just go
and build a shopping mall you know or
something and even if I'm not around
today you have to come to my grave and
just tell me you did it so that's my
task incredibly yeah I hope to achieve
that while he's still around yeah that's
right that's fine and that's one of the
things this week we're going to be we're
gonna be meeting some development
mentors and all kinds of stuff yes very
much
yeah Leslie you're an incredible person
I mean you were so humble as well you
say you said to me you said to me or
maybe I've just picked a really good
gold mining area and I said no you know
you are the support of my husband he's
living in Dubai
many people come of excuses you know or
it's difficult for me my husband's in
Dubai there's that the other but you're
someone that always looks on the bright
side always sees the opportunity instead
of looking at the problem are you aware
that that's partly part of your success
well I think now you put it like that
yeah absolutely because wherever there's
a problem you just got to resolve it all
to mately right so sometimes when you're
busy you don't have time to moan about
it you just really have just got to get
on with that and just find solutions you
know yeah brilliant can I tell you about
a project that went wrong yes I went
from okay so this was when I was in
Dubai my family are into property but
wasn't really involved until now that
I've come back more recently and um what
they owned like a building and they were
doing a conversion of an office into
four flats yeah and it just went really
wrong in terms of them they chose a
family friend who was the contractor and
I just think that that that contractor
was out of there death dead dead death
and so were we at that point but I
remember you know you have to get me as
redevelopment loans so the parents that
secured like a 12 lakh redevelopment
loan for that project and so we were
after the 12 not period I came home for
Christmas and then after Christmas we
got like a evaluation report that was
dropped through the post and I just
remembered it because it was it was a
bit stressful after that so we opened it
up and basically it basically was a
whole report of things that that told us
where what wasn't done and what was
wrong with the current works and I by
that point the contract had what we well
basically we let them go or they decided
not to work on it anymore so we were
kind of like in limbo
so that was my poor family my brother
was quite young then and my parents all
quite stressed because they were
obviously paying the bank every month
but the loan was only for 12 months so
there was a recall coming in so if the
bank recalled that redevelopment loan
and they said they had a charge on the
whole property that would have been we
would have lost that basically so I went
back to Dubai and basic project manage
that project until completion it took
seven months so what happened was I went
back and and put out a action plan spoke
with the lender and let and CC them into
the action plan but we were doing stuff
every day and the family were on the
ground in Cambridge trying to you know
make sure that certain tasks were done
but I didn't have any knowledge then
about sort of property
soundproofing you know fireproofing so
much getting the experts in to run the
tests
getting building control involved making
sure that you know we were compliant
with because at one point with the
previous contractors we didn't even have
we didn't apply for building control
consent so at one point they came in and
had to stop all works so that was before
I came back so I think it started from
then when I when I sort of realized okay
we can problem solve but I have to have
a team you know to do it with you and
just keep strong and I think keeping a
positive mindset is very important yeah
let's get things finished but we
finished within seven months after
having that report so that was a massive
goal for us and within that period we
refinanced twice so I got on set on good
terms with that particular lender but
there were high street banks so this you
know they're quite rigid with their
lending policies they couldn't really
extend that lending facility out for
much longer but what that lovely lady
did do was that she recommended a broker
to us and so that broke had got us a
bridging finance in place and then after
when the flats had completed we
refinanced on the whole thing yeah yeah
sounds very stressful what did you learn
from that experience it's really good to
have a proper plan before you start yeah
yeah because we probably spent maybe
double the money yeah yeah because we
had to reach out I had to like with the
help of the family on the ground reached
out to all these subcontractors that
bring them together yeah important to
have a plan important to have a team as
you said amber we learnt so much yeah so
much so I think that that experience was
invaluable because it was we could have
lost that building yeah which would have
been I think we would have really cried
over that because that was the building
that my parents first brought when they
came to the UK it's where their business
started so it means a lot yeah yeah and
also it was in that building when they
started their restaurant business in the
basement because we were quite poor my
parents weren't that wealthy because
they might well it migrated from Taiwan
New England by remember sleeping are
three in that basement for a couple of
months yeah that building holds a lot of
sentimental value that's great that's
great well yeah I mean it was probably
there's a problems it's not all smooth
sailing is it at all no I think it just
depends how you deal with that because I
think everything is solvable but you
just got to reach out the help you need
to and that's what you're so good at now
you yes you find the people you ask for
help and then at the same time you you
give back and you help people that are
struggling and and it could do with
something up ideas and inspiration from
you so that's fantastic
thank you sharing that tell me about so
that was the first property oh yeah
sorry
no it's right which is doing really well
is that still continuing to bring in
really good profit yes it is with
service accommodation though it does
vary a bit obviously I heard that sort
of during December January is kind of
like Earth quite a period so we'll have
to see how that goes and how we deal
with that but hey if you're making like
that much money that much profit the
other month it's not such a bad thing
that's a good point
tell me about so that was your first
deal we could go through all five six
she liked that we could be here all day
tell me about the latest deal that
you've just got going through at the
moment yeah so the later still is it's a
four-bedroom house with a basement flat
in sorry in the basement and it this one
was through word of mouth again but
without going into that too much
originally we weren't thinking about
taking this property on I was thinking
about passing it on to somebody else
yeah for a fee yeah and so but what
happened was we've got a phone a phone
call in and this is also contact in the
Middle East that we have a Middle
Eastern family we've got six adults six
kids there 12 people in total and they
want to find someone the center of
Cambridge so so that's when you know
little bells went off and we put the to
tweed put the two together so we've got
you know we've got a con we got a can't
deal sign with Middle Eastern family and
then we signed a deal with the landlord
on this property so so in terms of
numbers though the Middle East and
families think about 30 days yeah we're
charging 350 a night off
a little discount and our rental for
that place is 2,800 but the first three
months is rental free so with all the
expenses so forth
the net profit is we're going to be
earning from that property is about
7,000 or next yeah well next month next
month yeah well that'd be expected to be
a continuing profit thereafter what are
your predictions based on your knowledge
and market research of the area and the
house I'm hoping that we can achieve a
little bit more especially especially
during September and October because the
normal going rate for that house would
be about 400 pounds but because they're
staying over a month we gave a bit of at
this for 7,000 pound a month us with a
discount yeah we're a disc yeah you said
to me the other day I think you actually
put it on the Academy what's up group
you said I'm so passionate I really
believe that you can become financially
free from one deal yeah so I think this
still demonstrates that right it depends
what people's whatever the independence
figure is the average wage is about two
and a half grand a month yeah that was
my initial goal just be independent all
that I say to you when we had our
one-to-one and you told me you go yeah
your spatula is too low most people said
most people's problem is not that they
set their goals too high yeah and this
it's that they set their goals too low
and hit yeah you've certainly not done
that yes much like I remember at your
crash course and when you asked what my
goals were I remember Wisconsin for
everybody and haven't done any public
speaking for a while remember I should
say ten thousands yeah you did but just
but I had a build up but you told me
that you thought that would take you 12
months yeah he's taking you like four
months I know so I'm really pleased yeah
of course yeah I'm really pleased so so
you believe anyone can become
financially free one day or do you need
the special Leslie magic bullet I think
anybody can come for an actually three
or one deal I think maybe people should
stop caring too much about what other
people say and what other people think
that sort of thing if you've got a goal
in mind just really go for it hmm yeah
why do some people that go to the crash
course
yeah go on to not succeed I think it's
because when they maybe when they go
about approaching the initial experience
to get a deal maybe they get a bit of a
knock back and they lose confidence from
that and just think it's not working
so I would say you should never give up
may just change your strategy a bit yeah
yeah so for me like I mentioned a bit
earlier I found it a bit hard going for
real estate agents yes yeah and I didn't
particularly like it because you have to
put so much money down like a deposit so
sorry that's one more thing when you're
doing a rent to rent strategy you don't
really put a deposit down because you
have to invest into the property so is
it a bit cheeky so we asked for that so
usually you explain that sort of
commercial and later language but you
just got to keep going you know and
tweak your strategy a bit you know if
it's not working fix it don't turn back
yeah and also have a look within
yourself is that the way you're
presenting you know your deal that you
know is not believable are you doing it
of confidence yeah you know that sort of
thing I think some people why they fail
is because they don't believe that it
can be done yeah they don't believe in
their self and that belief system comes
across and they carry that and when
they're talking to landlords and agents
and when they do deals they've almost
got this posture this stench about them
that says I'm doing something dirty I'm
trying to trick you but actually we're
really helping landlords we've got a
good service when you're doing rent to
med service accommodation it works you
work just do it right to rent in my
opinion is the best service the
landlords out there because where else
are you gonna find a tenant that manager
manages your property for free invests
into the property and gives you a
guaranteed friend yeah what would you
say to someone that said why doesn't the
landlord just rent it out that way
themselves why do they pass it on to you
I mean I've got an answer for that board
your answer be landlords don't want the
hassle and a lot of landlords might not
even live in this country yeah I'm for a
lot of landlords they're quite happy to
receive a certain market rent as well
you know maybe they don't really have
massive aspirations of course the more
they get for their money is better but I
think they actually just want a
hands-off hassle-free experience and for
them the serviced accommodation route
would be
risky or or I think more than anything
is just about lack of knowledge they
don't know how to run the business like
we run the business yeah I'm also sorry
to answer your question about why
certain certain people find it really
hard to deal with bland laws they feel
like they're doing something wrong right
yeah and if it's landlords I also think
that lack of knowledge I get a lot of
like queries like oh is this not is this
illegal you know is this subletting
essentially and essentially it is but it
really just depends on what contrast
you've got in place and make it you know
illegal setup yeah yeah absent and your
background is a lawyer and you know that
we do things properly yeah absolutely
cuz that I'm a bit was stickler for that
obviously otherwise would be my
reputation on the line right yeah yeah I
mean there's gonna be two types of
people watching this video right now
there's going to be some people that are
like wow that's so inspiring I really
want to take action and they're gonna
get up they're gonna book on the crash
course they're gonna they're gonna start
talking to agents they're gonna really
throw himself out there and there's
going to be other people that that say
oh that sounds too good to be true or
they come up with excuses why for them
it's different I mean what would you say
firstly to the first group the people
that are really inspired and want to
take action what would be your first
step steps to them you guys are awesome
go for it yeah yeah life's too short if
you really want to you know if this is
what you want to do and you know it's
property then definitely go for it
you know invest in investment getting
the education that will you know answer
those questions that you've got you know
and think just go and do the work it was
it wasn't easy though in the beginning
you know you've got to put the
groundwork here but now yeah people give
up after a month I think I've tried a
month but you and your first month think
any deals but you grew yourself and you
grow in knowledge and you know that
certainly in the Academy you never go
over question unanswered yeah absolutely
even on the crash course I'm like anyone
you know I take questions yeah what
would you say to the latter the latter
group that us that are coming up with
reasons why that may be what some people
do is they try and they try and
discredit you in order to justify their
lack of results what would you say to
someone that trying to trying to do that
will say I don't know whatever whatever
these silly read skews more just
to them or would you just tell him to
stop watching the video go back to their
job well yeah that is one answer like so
because some people who discredit me I
do actually care because the people I
care about my family you know and your
cabin family yeah we know we come and
see your houses and we sit with you for
dinner and we know we know the results
you can yeah and if they were if they're
really serious about succeeding they
should never quit too soon yeah you know
it's all about you know what can you do
to get YouTube from A to B yeah right
yeah yeah I'm not asking you to do
anything illegal no you got to do it
you've got to be ethical moral add value
legal but and be yourself but nobody's
gonna really want to deal with you if
you're you know if you don't you're not
coming across as confident if you're not
sincere yeah you know or if you're a bit
negative in any way yeah I don't think
let's say a lot if you know a landlord
starts giving you objects that comes up
you know their concerns so I've had to
deal with landlords and you address
those concerns I mean if you start
agreeing with them that's not really
going to get you the deal what would you
say as we wrap up your aspirations on
out for the next six seven eight months
of your academy now it's about capital I
want to earn some a good chunk of
capital yes yeah development baby yeah
you've got that now at the development
program this week yeah I'm looking
really looking forward to it
so I've set myself a goal by in in 12
months yeah with me 12 months yeah so I
want to earn six hundred thousand pounds
in terms of whether it's from selling
off property well from or from
refinancing Leslie let's go make it
happen
you're an absolute pleasure I love
working with you and you know how do I
like working with me because I tend to
say you make a move by make ten moves is
that true yes yes absolutely I think
that you're you're a mentor with a lot
of foresight if that makes any sense as
in you know here's your strategy but
what are you going to be doing five
years time and you remember in our first
one to one you sort of painted a picture
but we had to you know you had to get it
out of me and what I really wanted and
you know we painted that picture of what
I was going to be doing in you know five
years time and where I wanted
be so we're heading in the right
direction absolutely yeah absolutely
awesome thank you so much Olivia that me
too
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time